diot tourner s'excuser écouter
aujourd'hui je trouve pour une vidéo
spéciale que j'aurais aimé ne jamais
faire tout simplement vous en doutez
sans rapport à ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dernier soir un truc terrible
abominable ya même pas de mots pour
décrire cette barbarie et le fait est
que j'avais besoin de faire une petite
vidéo pour évacuer un peu on est tous
extrêmement mal lié à ces événements et
moi y compris
et à ma manière d'évacuer c'était de
faire une vidéo voilà la manière la plus
naturelle pour moi c'était ça je voulais
pas après ça met une vidéo en ligne et
nous ça commence au mode énergique et
serra comme avant comme si s'était rien
passé alors que s'est passé quelque
chose et on ne peut pas l'ignorer
bah je vais pas en parler a extrêmement
longtemps mais je voulais surtout vous
parlez de 2,2 comment dire de cette
solidarité que j'ai pu remarquer qu' qui
réchauffe le coeur nos situations
pareilles de voir que tout le monde
s'est uni
tout le monde a voulu essayer d'aider
comme ils le pouvaient que se soit en
retweetant les avis de recherche que ce
soit en allant donner son sang enfin il
y avait plein de façons d'aider comme on
le pouvait parce que c'est hyper
frustrant dans cette situation c'est que
on a affaire à quelque chose qu'on
déteste plus que tout qui nous qui nous
affligent et on ne peut rien faire on ne
peut rien faire pour ne pas ressusciter
les gens qui sont décédés on peut pas
soigner les blessés en un claquement de
doigts on peut pas d'un coup anéantir le
tourisme on peut rien faire de tout ça
donc c'est hyper frustrant quand même
situation on espère juste que les gens
qui sont en place et vont faire le
nécessaire pour que ça se reproduise
plus jamais et malgré tout j'ai pu
constater que des gens ont été des des
vrais héros sur le terrain je veux dire
des victimes de ce qui s'est passé des
gens qui ont sauvé d'autres gens qui ont
mis leur vie en péril pour aider les
autres qui ont enfin - dans ces
situations là j'aime bien dans ces cas
là pardon j'aime bien me rattacher à ça
assez belle action à ses actes héroïques
à cette solidarité j'aime bien la
l'observer et il prendre part même j'ai
moi-même rte ce que je pouvais au niveau
des avis de recherche mais c'est rien
mais quand on fait tout ça finalement on
a quand même pu aider un petit peu dans
tout ce malheur les gens je voulais
aussi a donc je voulais vous féliciter
pour ça parce que je suis sûr qu'on a
énormément d'entre vous qui ont
contribué à ça il y avait même une fille
de 15 ans qui a créé un compte twitter
où elle publier les avis de recherche
parce que les proches d
débat d'aidé recherché était très très
très inquiet et purée ça doit être
insurmontable de se dire que qu'un
proche était au bataclan ou dans le coin
on n'a pas nouvelle on sait pas ce qui
lui est arrivé et c'est et voilà ça
c'est très émouvant de voir qu'autant de
gens se mobiliser pour pour aider comme
il le pouvait mais je me répète mais
c'est que ça m'a vraiment beaucoup
touché de voir ça je voulais vraiment
remercier aussi toutes les forces de
l'ordre toutes les forces j'avais jamais
le dise terme depuis dix ans mais je le
dis je pense que ce moment adéquat tout
ce qui est policier tout ce qui est
pompier tout ce qui est médecin
chirurgien
enfin n'importe qui qui a qui a apporté
son soutien dans cette histoire voilà
avoir un petit peu de biens dans tout ce
mal c'est quand même ça va chauffer un
petit peu le cas et puis voilà j'ai pas
grand chose d'autre à ajouter à part à
part que je suis que je suis affligé que
je suis bacon qu'on est tous quoi je
pense parler au nom de toute notre
communauté
si des gens qui ont été affectés par ces
événements que ce soit de manière
directe ou indirecte
et bien soyez forts on vous encourage
vraiment il faut avancer il faut prendre
de l'avant il c'est très difficile je
peux pas m'imaginer parce que je le vis
pas mais mais je m'en doute courage à
vous vraiment au nom des quatre millions
de personnes avec 100 sur cette chaîne
on vous envoie ce avec 4 millions de
courage je taxé vous aidera et puis et
puis voilà essayons de tous prendre de
l'avant les laissons pas gagné ce qu'ils
veulent c'est instaurer la terreur dont
ils ont attaqué des gens qui se
divertissent et devant un concert qui
buvait un verre qui voilà qu'il y avait
des loisirs finalement été tout ce qui
est synonyme de bonheur c'est ce que ces
gens pratiquer à ce moment là les
concerts la musique les regroupements
les discussions tout ça et ils ont
attaqué ça directement et ben ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse tout simplement c'est
que on on continue de nous de s'amuser
et d'avoir du bonheur et de pratiques
est tout ce qui nous fait plaisir tout
ce qui nous fait du bien
par exemple pour moi faire des vidéos
voulait proposer et vous bat passer un
bon moment devant il faut qu'on continue
tout ça il faut pas qu'on s'arrête à
cause d'eux qu'on leur montre que ce
qu'ils font ça sert absolument à rien et
je suis sûr qu'on va y arriver c'est sûr
et
et puis voilà dans mon cas je veux y
arriver et pour y arriver j'avais besoin
de faire cette vidéo
bon j'espère que vous comprendrez et
puis voilà aucun cut rien j'avais juste
envie de te parler un petit peu tout
simplement j'espère que vous ça va et
puis on va tous s'en remettre petit à
petit mais sans oublier ce qui s'est
passé ce vendredi et à et ça ira ça ira
avec le temps et j'espère que vous
quotidiens continueront d'être bien un 2
vous aurez toujours du bonheur du
plaisir dans ce que vous faites que vous
atteindrez vos rêves
et puis et puis voilà j'ai un d'autre à
ajouter gros courage à tous ceux qui ont
été victimes de ça vraiment et mes
condoléances à ceux qui ont des proches
ou des amis décédés au nom des quatre
millions de personnes sur cette chaîne
youtube encore une fois si ça peut aider
tant mieux je l'espère et puis a très
vite dans une prochaine vidéo pour un
max de bonheur un max d'amusement un max
de divertissement et on ne laissera pas
gagné à bientôt